[Musique]
tu as fait tout ça pour la thune alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya très peu de business
law ça vous intéresse plus de faire de
la thune peut-être pour moi la série
elle reflète rfet l'univers du rap en
tout point c'est ce que je me suis dit
quand j'ai vu les épisodes aussi en tant
que spectateur et tu la prends tellement
pleine face que tu dis ok je sais plus
délié le vrai du faux
tapply hamas tahar qui arrive va dans le
studio b tu vérifies si la crème en
voilà pourquoi parce qu'il faut pas
qu'ils se croisent toutes les histoires
de deux traits de crédibilité ou toutes
ces histoires d'égo est ce que vous
pensez vous pouvez boire et conseiller
en avril a rappelé pour seraient
concernés là qu'est ce qui fait que deux
mecs qui vend des millions de disques se
retrouvent parlant devant l'aéroport
stop sur la gueule il en train de
refaire une beauté charisme fait on
comprend pourquoi ça peut arriver et à
quel point c'est réaliste
je savais déjà un petit peu tout ce qui
se passait derrière dans les studios
dans l'est la paix
dans les maisons disque dans tout ça les
enregistrements l'écriture les droits à
compagnie la rivalité entre entre entre
les artistes
plus globalement c'est vrai qu'il a il a
ce côté un peu rêveur d'arriver dans un
milieu qui connaît pas et où il a fait
fantasmer depuis des années des années
sauf qu'en fait c'est pas exactement ça
enfin que si je comprends bien tout
efois en vérité il ya aucun buzz autant
demain ce sera le parcours d'apache il
est c'est le parcours d'un mec qui est
propulsé dans un milieu médiatique est
là dans le milieu du rap mais enfin
c'est un truc où tu te jettes son filet
quoi tu vois chaque semaine ya booska-p
ou demolition qui sortent de nouvelles
têtes à la roquette hongrie l'effort
c'est pas le seul tout au long de cette
série il est confronté à des des
embûches qui sont très réalistes soit
qu'ils sont des choses qui sont arrivées
sur des choses qui vraiment pourrait
arriver il vit les villes et mauvais
contrats les contrats des contrats un
peu foireux il vit le producteur qui
veut juste se faire bronzer sur son dos
6 annonce une tournée solo je les envoie
dans l'oubli et moi je le baiserais xvi
le rappeur qui nous fait croire que
c'est son gars alors qu en fait pas du
tout pas tous se partager le gâteau je
vous dis direct à dire quoi ça y'a pas
cette place pour mostar carnage n'a pas
géré ma maison ma star ne voit pas
arriver il ne voit pas arriver il se
prend un coup mais il se dit qu'en fait
il va l'étendre au fur et à mesure de
leur relation et se rend compte qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à l'éteindre
donc c'est là où on rentre un peu plus
dans le dip un peu plus dans le dur où
justement il se sent menacé
j'ai un plan dans la tête pour trois
montées très vite ça profiter autant à
toi comme moi tu me fous tu me suis moi
[Musique]
la star n'est pas la prison et s'est
montré presque tout le temps j'aimerais
que tout le monde car match et une poule
1 que va chercher ma star justement pour
essayé d'entraver la carrière de clément
je vais le prendre ils étouffent ou deux
je vais le lâcher sur le clément
c'est un très bon rappeur et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que justement c'est là
tout ce côté animal enfin dans son
rapport dont le père a perdu qu'on
maintient dans la vie casquette
intégrale des masques ou ténois bas
autant d'habileté plutôt trafic
cariat mérité automne le focus de prêter
oui moi un mec comme carnage envie de
croiser dans une réelle à 3 heures du
matin moi tous des berges et six mois
pour thann fans au film de la saison je
pense que vraiment ce qui va apprendre
sur le même c'est que ma c'est que
justement faut pas être trop gentil en
fait je pense que ce sont à la fois en
fait c'est un mec durable qui dans le
calcul dans l'analyse et dans la
stratégie
moralement c'est un coup marketing qui
l'entravent retourner contre toulon nous
n'avons pas plus de précisions à l'heure
actuelle mais il pourrait s'agir d'un
règlement de comptes validés une
création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal